[Musica]
guerra e pace uno dei più alti
capolavori letterari di tutti i tempi
altro in tutti i sensi visto che a 1.400
pagine tolstoj impiego sei anni per
scriverlo lo terminò nel 1869 tre anni
dopo
dall'altra parte del mondo in nevada una
capsula del tempo venne collocata nella
pietra angolare di questo edificio
questo edificio
una capsula del tempo si si tratta di
contenitori né più né meno che vengono
riempiti tipicamente con oggetti di uso
quotidiano e nascosti protetti in modo
da essere poi riaperti in un'epoca
lontana è un modo per comunicare con il
futuro questa capsula del tempo venne
riaperta nel 2019 quando l'edificio
venne demolito dentro c'erano più di 40
oggetti copie di giornali dallari
d'argento un'armonica un cavatappi
insomma materiale vario che ha rivisto
la luce dopo 147 anni
e sempre in nevada nel 1996 a due passi
dall'area 51
un'altra capsula del tempo venne
seppellita dalla troupe del film
indipendence day da riesumare questa
volta nel 2050
quanto manca al 2050 stato così questo
sono io
nel 1992 avevo 10 anni ecco il 2050
vista da noi tanto quanto il 1992 siamo
esattamente a metà strada
per chi non c'era lasciatevelo dire il
mondo del 1992 era abbastanza diverso da
quello di oggi
pensate che a casa io avevo una macchina
da scrivere ed era una cosa normale a
quel tempo se qualcuno mi avesse detto
nel 2021 tutti avremo in tasca un
computer miniaturizzato con schermo
touch identificazione biometrica e
accesso praticamente illimitato
all'inter
le cifre guardato come si guarda un
pazzo eppure eccoci qui
all'epoca ero già un grande appassionato
di astronomia e anche in quel campo
tante cose sono cambiate da allora il
sistema solare per esempio aveva nove
pianeti non otto come oggi plutone non
era ancora stato declassato a pianeta
mano avvenne nel 2006 e non era ancora
mai stato visitato questa era l'immagine
di plutone più dettagliata che avevamo
all'epoca oggi è questa per dire la fece
la sonda new horizons quando sorvolò
plutone nel 2015 nel 92 non avevamo
ancora nemmeno scoperto la cometa hale
bopp la più sensazionale a memoria
d'uomo e oltre anzi non avevamo proprio
nemmeno mai stati su una cometa ci siamo
arrivati nel 2014 quando la missione
rosetta fece atterrare un piccolo
l'under sulla superficie di questa
cometa 67p churyumov gerasimenko
all'epoca inoltre non si conosceva
nessun pianeta extrasolare in orbita
attorno a stelle simili al sole
oggi invece ne contiamo più di 4.300 e
nessuno aveva mai visto foto di panorami
marziani perché non c'erano
semplicemente nessun rover era mai stato
su marte il primo su tournaire sarebbe
arrivato solo nel 1997 in questo momento
mentre vi sto parlando su marte ci sono
ben tre rover operativi di cui uno
cinese
se ci pensate
il 92 non è poi così distante
voglio dire io me lo ricordo
eppure il mondo è cambiato profondamente
da allora ecco immaginate quanto potrà
cambiare ancora da qui al 2050 i bambini
che oggi hanno dieci anni avranno l'età
che io vivo adesso saranno adulti mentre
io sarò un signore anziano di quasi 70
anni e forse qualche capello in meno di
adesso ma non parliamo di questo signore
anziano parliamo piuttosto di lei
questa eva o meglio sarà eva nascerà nel
2050 da qualche parte nel mondo come
sarà il mondo di era cosa aspetterà
difficile dirlo sicuramente
moltissime cose meravigliose che ai
nostri occhi appaiono del tutto
fantascientifiche
ma non tutto sembrerà meraviglioso ai
suoi occhi sono molte le sfide che
incombono su di lei è la più grande è
senza dubbio la crisi climatica dovuta
al riscaldamento globale è una crisi già
cominciata e già in corso le nostre
attività
produzione di energia
allevamenti agricoltura gestione dei
rifiuti e così via e mettono
nell'atmosfera grandi quantità di gas
serra principalmente anidride carbonica
e metano
parliamo di decine di miliardi di
tonnellate emesse ogni anno si chiamano
gas serra perché aiutano l'atmosfera
terrestre a trattenere il calore del
sole proprio come una grande serra come
conseguenza la terra si scalda bene
dall'inizio dell'epoca industriale cioè
circa un secolo e mezzo fa i livelli di
anidride carbonica in atmosfera hanno
raggiunto valori che qui sulla terra non
si vedevano da almeno due milioni di
anni sono saliti di oltre il 50 per
cento
e tutto questo non solo secolo e mezzo
questo è il risultato
dietro di me potete vedere come il
pianeta si è scaldato dal 1880 ad oggi
vi basti sapere che le nostre emissioni
di gas serra hanno fatto aumentare la
temperatura media del pianeta di 1,1
gradi rispetto all'epoca preindustriale
11 gradi magari non vi sembra molto ma
pensate a che effetto farebbe lo stesso
aumento di temperatura sul vostro corpo
stareste male cerchereste un medico
perché avreste la febbre ecco il pianeta
oggi ha la febbre noi l'abbiamo
provocata noi la stiamo facendo salire
ora
spero che il clima della terra cambiato
molte volte in passato non è certo
questa la prima volta ma questa volta è
diverso perché è la prima volta che la
colpa è nostra
ad agosto 2021 è uscito l'ultimo report
della ip sì sì l'organismo delle nazioni
unite che valuta tutta la produzione
scientifica mondiale sui cambiamenti
climatici sono più di 14 mila articoli
scientifici
se si parla di clima è questo il
documento di riferimento e questo
documento esordisce così è
inequivocabile che l'influenza umana ha
scaldato l'atmosfera gli oceani e le
terre emerse
l'inequivocabile com'è che ne siamo così
certi per questo motivo questo grafico
ci dice che tutti i nostri modelli
climatici che ormai sono molto buoni e
curati riescono a riprodurre cioè a
spiegare l'aumento di temperatura media
del pianeta che osserviamo cioè la linea
blu soltanto se nei nostri modelli
inseriamo anche le missioni umane di gas
serra
cioè la linea arancione
se invece non inseriamo le nostre
missioni non riusciamo minimamente a
spiegare l'aumento di temperatura
la linea piatta grigia questo significa
che le nostre emissioni di gas serra
sono di gran lunga il motore principale
del riscaldamento globale attualmente in
corso in altre parole la responsabilita
di questa crisi è nostra
il termometro mondiale se ne ha già più
1,1 gradi rispetto all'epoca
preindustriale
secondo lei pizzi si la soglia di
sicurezza si trova a più 1,5 gradi oltre
questo limite le conseguenze purtroppo
diventeranno drammatiche e non manca
molto a più 1,5 gradi
indovinate un po dove saremo nel 2050 se
non si farà nulla ve lo dico io saremmo
più 2 gradi significa catastrofe e non
solo sempre secondo lei pieces il 2050
l'anno di nascita di eva sarà anche
l'anno di non ritorno se l'umanità non
azzera completamente le emissioni
globali di gas serra entro quella il
superamento della soglia di più 1,5
gradi sarà inevitabile è questo il mondo
che vogliamo lasciare alla piccola eva
non credo proprio eppure l'orologio
ticchetta nel 2050 si fa sempre più
vicino secondo un report della banca
mondiale il 2050 potrà vedere fino a 140
milioni di profughi climatici
ripeto 140 milioni
tutte persone in fuga da siccità
desertificazione o magari colpite da
inondazioni uragani incendi e altri
eventi che all'epoca non chiameremo meno
più estremi perché saranno una norma a
più due gravi cioè dove saremo nel 2050
se non faremo nulla
intere nazioni insulari come le maldive
rischieranno di scomparire completamente
per via dell'innalzamento del livello
dei mari alle maldive hanno già
cominciato a pompare sabbia dal fondale
marino per recuperare almeno in parte le
terre emerse che il mare sta pian piano
togliendo i suoi abitanti
ma se pensate che questo sia un problema
di qualcun altro che abita lontano beh
guardate qui
questa è l'italia non è una qualche
remota isola in mezzo all'oceano l'area
che vedete colorata in rosso è a rischio
di inondazioni continue nel 2050 se non
faremo nulla inondazioni continue
per caso con conoscete qualcuno che
abita da quelle parti
io sì
in uno di quei puntini rossi io sono
nato sono cresciuto lì ho la mia
famiglia i miei ricordi o amici persone
care se pensate che il riscaldamento
globale sia un problema di qualcun altro
sappiate che già oggi il 21 per cento
del territorio italiano è a rischio di
desertificazione
21 per cento eva potrebbe essere vostra
figlia potrebbe essere vostre nipote
costretta magari emigrare nel nord
dell'europa solo per poter vivere
dignitosamente e questo che vogliamo per
lei la crisi climatica è probabilmente
una delle maggiori sfide che l'umanità
abbia mai dovuto affrontare nella sua
storia possiamo ancora farcela non è
troppo tardi siamo ancora in tempo ma
dobbiamo agire immediatamente
desertificazione aumento del livello dei
mari aumento dei fenomeni meteorologici
estremi sono già una realtà sono già
cose che si leggono nei titoli di
giornali non possiamo più ignorarlo
siamo già in emergenza
io purtroppo non ho soluzioni da darvi
come del resto non le ha nessuno in
questo momento tanto meno i divulgatori
non chiediamo soluzioni a chi ci sta
raccontando il problema esigiamo le
invece dalla politica facciamo capire
alla sfera della politica che tutti noi
pretendiamo azioni immediate ora io dal
canto mio riporto quello che dicono i
climatologi ma non sono un climatologo
sono soltanto un astrofisico
allora vi chiederete perché vi sto
parlando di tutto questo vi parlo di
tutto questo perché sono convinto che
l'astronomia ci aiuterà a salvare e va
sicuramente l'aiuto è anche pratico
pensate solamente ai satelliti in orbita
attorno alla terra che monitorano i
parametri del nostro pianeta senza di
questi non sapremo misurare con
precisione
l'entità della crisi climatica
probabilmente non ci renderemo nemmeno
del tutto conto della situazione in cui
ci troviamo
l'aiuto che ci dà l'astronomia in questo
campo è fondamentale ma diciamo che è un
aiuto che l'astronomia da soltanto agli
addetti ai lavori attraverso la
tecnologia
ma c'è un aiuto forse ancora più
importante che l'astronomia può dare a
ciascuno di noi già ora ed è il fatto
che riesce a mettere il problema nella
giusta prospettiva
vedete noi esseri umani siamo in grado
di mettere in atto reazioni automatiche
al pericolo quando lo percepiamo come
imminente nel tempo e prossimo nello
spazio nella nostra scala di individui
ma la crisi climatica agisce su scale si
è spaziali sia temporali molto più
grandi di queste troppo grandi per
innescare nel nostro cervello tutte
quelle reazioni che invece sarebbero
utili in questo momento per contrasto il
pericolo la crisi climatica è imminente
si è prossima si ma non nella nostra
scala individuale nella scala di noi
come specie come collettività come
umanità e questo poi ha un enorme
impatto su di noi come individui e
questo che dobbiamo capire per
affrontare la crisi climatica
dobbiamo percepirla come una minaccia
personale e per percepirla in questo
modo il trucco è
ridimensionare le scale su cui agisce
facendo cene sembrare più piccole e
questa è una cosa che l'astronomia sa
fare benissimo
perché non c'è niente come vederci
dall'alto per farci capire quanto la
nostra prospettiva individuale sia miope
guardate questa foto si chiama hearts
era la essa fu scattata dagli astronauti
della missione apollo 8 della nasa nel
uno di questi astronauti bill anders
disse poi una frase che personalmente
trovo molto illuminante e la frase
questa siamo venuti fin qui per
esplorare la luna ma la cosa più
importante che abbiamo scoperto è la
terra
si dice che questa immagine abbia
contribuito più di ogni altra a dare il
via ai grandi movimenti ambientalisti
perché ha reso l'umanità improvvisamente
consapevole di quanto sia fragile la sua
casa nel cosmo la terra
ecco è questo l'effetto che l'astronomia
può fare su tutti noi l'astronomia ci
aiuta a salvarci
pensate all'aumento del livello dei mari
di cui vi parlavo poco fa
magari questo per noi non è un problema
ma lo è per chi deve lottare ogni giorno
con il mare e per chi dal mare e dai
suoi capricci dipende in tutto e per
tutto per la propria sopravvivenza
certo noi possiamo pensare che i
problemi di questo pescatore non abbiano
che fare coi nostri lui e ai suoi noi ne
abbiamo altri ma guardate questa
immagine
la vedete quel piccolo puntino laggiù in
fondo
quel puntino e la terra
vista dalla sonda voyager 1 nel 1990 da
una distanza di 6 miliardi di chilometri
moltissimo per noi ma un'inezia da un
punto di vista astronomico
guardate questa immagine di temi
pensate che il destino di quel pescatore
sia slegato dal nostro
oppure vi rendete conto che ci troviamo
tutti sulla stessa barca
questo per quanto riguarda le scale
spaziali
poi ci sono quelle temporali perché il
riscaldamento globale non si vede dalla
temperatura che c'è oggi fuori dalla
finestra ma da medie di temperatura in
periodo di almeno 30 anni che guarda
caso è giusto il tempo che manca da qui
al 2050 ora 30 anni possono sembrare
molti ma ve lo ricordate guerra e pace
1400 pagine ecco se tutta la storia
dell'universo 14 miliardi di miliardi di
anni occupasse per intero questo libro
ogni pagina del libro corrisponderebbe a
10 milioni di anni di storia significa
che in questo libro la terra è nata 450
pagine fa i dinosauri estinti non più di
sei pagine e mezzo fa e noi esseri umani
beh se questa è tutta la storia
dell'universo questa
questa
è l'intera storia umana
sta tutta nell'ultima riga
del libro
e nel punto che chiude l'ultima frase in
quel piccolo punto c'è tutto il tempo
passato dall inizio dell epoca
industriale cioè tutto il tempo che
abbiamo impiegato per arrivare questa
crisi e c'è anche tutto il tempo che
manca da qui al 2050 cioè la nascita di
eva e vai già in questo punto
crisi climatica è globale e per
risolverla dobbiamo ragionare in modo
globale come specie ed è questo l'aiuto
più grande che ci può dare l'astronomia
ci fa vedere come un tutt'uno nello
spazio e nel tempo eva si trova nello
stesso minuscolo puntino azzurro in cui
ci troviamo anche noi si trova nello
stesso minuscolo punto del grande libro
in cui ci troviamo anche noi
eva non è ancora nata
ma nascerà e vivranno il mondo che noi
sceglieremo di consegnarle la sua vita
dipenderà anche da scelte che noi
possiamo fare oggi
che cosa scegliamo
vogliamo salvarla
grazie